hi jerry welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi guys good to talk to you you too man
what's up
i need some advice on how to get out of
some stupid that i did um
i was totally debt-free house everything
whole business i'm 60 years old
i had my own company last november my
accountant advised me to
it would help my expenses if i purchased
a vehicle
so for my company so i did that now i
have a 30 000
car that i'm driving around and i still
have to pay for it well then prove it
hit in march
and my hundred thousand dollar income is
now probably gonna be about fifty
thousand this year
um so i did uh my emergency fund i still
have about
14 15 000 left but it's windowing
quickly obviously i am
did you start going back to work
actually this week so that's going to
help out
but um so what would be wrong with
selling the car and firing your
accountant
yeah really and that's the truth yeah no
i mean
sell the car and fire your accountant
really yeah
well um okay i do have some money that i
could pay for with
i guess can i how much money do you well
in my uh i'm 60 years old so i have a
retirement of about
570 000 um
my i have another three other little
odds and end iras about fifty thousand
uh you cash them out with any pen
without any penalty you're going to pay
taxes on it
right i guess that's where the question
comes from should i do or
should i do that well the question comes
i i still don't understand that
whether you have a car you wanted or
your accountant wanted it
well they advise that it would help with
my business
it doesn't they're stupid that was
dumber than dirt
i mean you didn't make you didn't make
30 000 because of that dadgum car
no okay that's just dumb okay
it is i mean think about it the guy's
just he's trying to save you money but
listen anytime you take a tax deduction
it's not a hundred percent savings on
your taxes he's trying to run
save you on your taxes well i can save
you on your taxes give thirty thousand
dollars to a ministry
and guess what you have a thirty
thousand dollar write-off and you don't
have thirty thousand dollars in debt
so i mean but guess what you don't get a
thirty thousand dollar
deduction on your taxes you get your tax
rate times thirty thousand dollars as
your deduction
that's why you need to fire your
accounting than then i do math and so
really really really
yeah i did get a new account good okay
we got that part solved so the only
question is do you want to keep the car
if you had 30 000
piled up in the middle of the table
would you go buy a car right now just
like that one if you didn't own that one
i'd have to have something i mean uh
might would you go buy a car
just like that one if you had thirty
thousand dollars piled up in the middle
of the table
probably not just like this one probably
wouldn't need this much of a car
no that tells you exactly what y'all do
jerry
um this whole thing was birthed in a bad
idea and paying it off doesn't make it a
good idea
if you want to pay it off and keep it
i'm okay dude you got plenty of money
i'm just challenging the whole
decision-making process for you i'm just
pushing back on you to shake you up a
little bit make you think
make you think you don't need to cause
your accountant's editor because dave
ramsey said do it either one